foreign
she is in Springfield Illinois hi
Genesee how are you
hi I'm doing great how are you better
than I deserve what's up
hi
um so I am a fresh new baby graduate
um and I'm about 217 000 in debt
um both of my parents didn't go to
college so I don't really have anybody
to talk to about like loan repayment and
things of that nature I did luckily get
gifted your course from a Facebook group
that I'm in and I'm on step two but I'm
wondering
um as a so I'm a single parent
um I'm 26 and she's 10 I had her at 16.
and I just did School straight through
so no working in between High School
undergrad and then I just graduated from
veterinary school oh wow I have my
doctorate wow good for you good for you
thank you very much I'm just wondering
how realistic it is you know because it
seems like I'll never get to step three
with that much debt and I know I like I
said I'm on step two in the in the
course and I see a lot of like married
couples we work with a lot we work with
a lot of veterinarians
um in Entre leadership uh because a lot
of them come through to learn how to run
their business the business aspect of
being a veterinarian and so what we're
what I'm discovering just in having
conversations with them is that there
are veterinarians
um working in a practice that don't own
the practice
lots of them that are making a hundred
and a quarter a hundred and a half
um there are a whole group of them too
that are making 60.
and 70.
um and so uh you know what I would tell
you is don't get too caught up in
a certain
area of veterinary medicine get caught
up in the area that can make you the
most money for a little while
so I've actually signed on
um to a practice it is a corporate
practice so I don't own it and I don't
have any stake in it I start Monday
actually okay and
um 105
000 a year ding ding sounds like my
information's accurate okay and you'll
be going up pretty quick in that that's
just your starting and so you'll be at
100 and a quarter within a short period
of time so I'm pretty close all right
and you're used to living on nothing
mm-hmm yeah because you've been a
college student your whole life
yeah
okay so so if you lived on nothing
what would how much is nothing
um my my rent at my house that I was
living in um from in my vet school was
about 5 50. I was one of five roommates
um and then my mom was helping me with
my daughter at that point in time
um so now when I move I've moved back to
my hometown
um my rent the rent here is pretty
insane it's going to be about for me to
rent and not you know have a mortgage
rental homes and Rental departments are
looking at about 1200 1100 to 1200 a
month okay and then you know that's 14
000 out of 105.
okay then we gotta eat we gotta eat and
we got to pay lights and we're not gonna
go buy a car on payments
yep I have I have a car I've owned it it
is on its last leg you're a veterinarian
just prop the leg up
all right
um and then yeah and then living expense
so here's here's what I'm saying all
right 50
55 000 a year minus taxes is the most
you can spend to live
the other fifty thousand goes on your
debt and in four years you're done
okay so you think it wouldn't be worth
signing up for like an income base
repayment
um and why would you want to stay in
debt the rest of your life
I don't okay let's get out of debt in
four years
okay just sooner okay I'm talking to a
woman who at the age of 16 with most
people
we're trying to figure out how blinker
works on their mom's car
had a child
and you have managed to be a mother and
a daughter and a graduate student and
now a veterinarian
making a hundred and five thousand at 26
years old you cannot sell me on the fact
that you can't quote unquote do
something you can do anything I would
fight you for them all the money in the
world
you're incredible my friend Jade warshaw
who also calls this show her and her
husband had almost half a million bucks
and they did not have veterinarian in
their holster
they were music students and they did it
here's what's going to be frustrating
for you
you have been waiting for this moment
for so long and you're Dr Genesee now
and that car is going to stay the same
and that lifestyle is going to stay the
same and that 10 year old kid that you
promised just wait just wait just wait
three more years to go oh they gotta
wait
because it's going to take you four
years it's gonna take you three to four
years to do this and you can also work
shifts on Saturdays and Sundays and
maybe even uh do emergency medicine
overnight if you need to and let your
kids stay with your mom every once in a
while if you go pick up another 50 Grand
doing that you can be out of debt in two
and a half years
okay so it doesn't seem unattainable you
can do this here's the big math okay
take 200 000 and divide it by the number
you're going to put on it a year
I put 50 a year on it out of your 105 a
minute ago then John added some work to
your life and we put another 40 or 50 on
it
so 50 a year into 200 is four right
right this is attainable
and by the way this is not static you're
not going to only make 105 for the next
four years
and the extra income you're not going to
only want to do that forever so but if
you go made another 30 or 40 000 bucks
and now we put 80 on this you know what
is 200 divided by eighty three
not even okay two and three quarter
right okay
you following me here it's a big number
math you don't have to do you don't have
to have a master's degree in math in
finance to pull this off you just divide
200 by the amount you're going to throw
at it and that tells you how many years
it's going to take for you to get this
done you're going to get it done very
very quickly and here's underneath the
math
my mom I've told the story on the show
my mom at 42 the age of 42 took her
first community college class one class
and it was either geometry or algebra
one of the two we took it together I was
in I was in high school
fast forward to 57 is when she graduated
with her PhD and she became a tenured
professor at 63 and I'm and she teaches
her last year at Oxford this summer in
in her 70s
I tell you that to tell you I had a
ringside seat to a mom who completely
transformed her life and it was hard and
she was busy and she had to miss games
and she was working on Saturdays and
Sundays writing papers and reading and
doing grad school work
and as an adult she took away every
single excuse I could ever have because
I got a ringside seat to watch and a
gangster be born and so your son is
gonna watch you and you're gonna feel
guilty I want you to think of the long
game he's going to watch his mom teach
him through action he can do anything
he's married though I mean his mom's a
warrior princess it's incredible you're
giving him the gift of us of a lifetime
yep